نغمه وتر هو اللقب الذي اختاره الفنان
السعودي شاب عمر العمر وعرف به خلال
ممارسه للغناء والعزف في السنوات الماضيه
عمري العمر مشاهدينا بدا
كفن برعته جعلته احد اكثر المتابعين على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عزفه الجميل وصوت
العذب زاد من معجبي خصوصا بعد تاسيس لقناه
على اليوتيوب وصلت مشاهداتها لقرابه نصف
مليار خلال عده سنوات فضلا عن ما يصل الى
مليون مشترك منذ بدايتها في العام 2017
معنى لا مشاهدينا من الرياض الفنان عمر
العمر صباح الخير يا عمر اهلا وسهلا
صباح النور يا مرحبا هلا وسهلا عمر يعني
انت بلشت
كفنان هاوي
حتى تلقب بنغمه وتر يعني كيف قدرت توصل
لهذا هذا المستوى
كثر الممارسه اولا كان صراحه هوايه عندي
هذا الموضوع
الممارسه والاستمراريه وكثر الاستماع
تول عندي زي المنظومه او المخزون الموسيقي
اللي الحمد لله طلع على اثر هذا
هذا المستوى طيب
انا راح اسالك بعد ما اسمع منك شيء الان
انا انا طماع انا ابي اسمع ايش راح تسمعنا
ابشر ابشر
اللي انت محبين اللي اللي على باله
خلاص امشي
خلاص بما انها الاغنيه الاولى اجل خليها
من اغاني
المشهوره يعني
[موسيقى]
الله على ذا الليل لو كان ما جابك
اشتاق لك
بالحيل لا يطول غيابك
الله على ذلين لو كان ما جابك
اشتاق لك
بالحيل لا يطول غيابك
ياللي هويتك ليل
والصبح قفا
والله
مات الحيل واقف على بابك
طبعا يعني من اشهر الاغاني اللي اشتهرت
وكانت هي سبب الشهره بالتاكيد اليوم
يقولون جيل الشباب لا اغانيه الخاصه
لمفرداته حتى الخاصه هل بالفعل بطلوا اللي
يحبون الطرب من جيل الشباب او الجيل
الجديد ما عاد يعجبهم
والله شوف من وجهه نظري انا اشوف العكس
صراحه بالعكس الان
الشباب كلهم توجهوا الى الاغاني القديمه
والطرب والاغاني اللي كانت في حقبه كذا
مفقوده
[موسيقى]
والدليل يعني تشوف ما شاء الله في
اليوتيوب الاغاني اللي جددناها والاغاني
اللي طلعت صارت يعني عليها مشاهدات عاليه
صارت تستوي من الاغاني الجديد طيب يعني
معروفه الاغنيه الخليجيه بشكل عام بانها
بتمتاز بكلمات جميله جدا وما زالت محافظه
على مستوى الكلمات وعمق المعاني بالنسبه
لك لما تختاري الكلمات شو هي الموضوعات
اللي بتحبها اكثر او هل عندك اي
معايير معينه بتتقيد فيها
اهم شيء عندي تكون يعني تكون القصيده
مكتمله الاركان يعني عاده انا احب صراحه
يعني قصائد العتاب والشوق والغزل
اتمحور دائما بين الثلاثه المواضيع هذه
عمر عمر يعني زميلنا عماد حكم قال لي لازم
لازم تطلب منه
فبالتالي بالتالي لازم لازم اسمعها منك
وختامها مسك كما كما يقال
احنا بنودع المشاهدين
واذا خلصت
مستمرين بابي اغنيه لطلال يلا
طلعوا من الداحش
[موسيقى]
احبك لين
اخرنا
واولنا ليالي القصر سهرنا ليل
اخرها
ومدري ويلي ويلي احبك لين
اخرنا
واولنا ليالي قصار سهرنا لين اخرها
ومدري ويلي ويلي
اسهر نجم اتمنى
تلاقي والاماني كبر افكر بس في لحظه
بحضن فيها
ايدينك اسهر نجم اتمنى
تلاقي
والاماني لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات